انتهينا من الجزء الاول الان الى الجزء
الثاني في هذه الانتخابات المهمه ماذا
مجلس النواب الامريكي الغرفه الادنى من
الكونجرس هذه السيده التي نراها الان هي
نانسي بيلوسي تسعى للحفاظ على اغلبيه
حزبها حزبها الديمقراطيه في مجلس النواب
اما كذا مكارتي زعيم الاقلي الجمهوريه
يريد ان يصبح رئيس المجلس الجديد بعد ان
غابت الاغلبيه عن حزبه لاربع سنوات الوضع
الحالي هو التالي لنشرحه اكثر هذا المجلس
يتكون من
مقعدا تحديدا همم لكن تشكيلته الحاليه
ينقصها ثلاثه انواع الاستقاله نائبه واحد
منهم ديمقراطي وهو شارليست الذي يرشح نفسه
لمنصبه حاكم ولايات فلوريدا ايضا
توفيت دائبه الثانيه
وهي الجمهوريه الثالثه عفوا هي الجمهوريه
جاكي وروسكي وتذكرون جاكي هي النائبه التي
بحث عنها جورج بعيدا بعد وفاتها بشهرين